hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for anime outbroad and today i will
be breaking down what happens after the
epic conclusion to the massive wano arc
in one piece what is going to be the
next arc what are the next major battles
in the series and how is this entire
enormous story going to end wano
absolutely changed everything in one
piece luffy's true devil fruit reveal
and awakening gear 5 the return of joy
boy the defeat of two freaking yonkos
that is just an incredible amount of
earth shattering moments for a single
arc and because wano changed so much so
quickly the story has no choice but to
get even more intense from here so let's
get into it you guys know how this works
if you enjoy our videos and you want to
see more in the future leave a quick
like and comment it only takes a second
but it really helps me with that youtube
algorithm and of course if you're new
here or maybe you watch our videos but
you just haven't taken the time to
subscribe yet do me a quick favor and
subscribe and hit the notification bell
it is a direct and completely free way
of supporting the channel finally this
video will contain one piece manga
spoilers so please proceed with caution
you have been warned okay so with two
emperors of the sea defeated which is
just so crazy by the way you would think
that the straw hats and the people of
wano would get some time to celebrate
and recuperate before taking on their
next challenge however that is not
necessarily the case back in chapter
1028
rob lucci informs the bowler hat wearing
cp-0 agent that a fleet of world
government ships is standing by near
wano and this fleet has been instructed
to invade wano and take direct control
of the kingdom on the off chance that
kaido loses just to be clear these are
not marine ships the insignia on their
sails is world government insignia not
marine insignia so this is a fleet that
is under the direct command of the world
nobles not the marines this means that
the admirals may not actually be here
but at the same time we have to assume
that this is an extremely strong fleet
after all the world government
dispatched this fleet to take down
whoever defeats kaido so they must be
prepared to take on an extremely strong
opponent on top of that they have been
ordered to take over all of wano their
mission is not just to step in and take
out the straw hats who have already been
weakened by the battle against kaido and
big mom no they are there to take direct
control of an entire kingdom for an
undisclosed period of time which is a
far more daunting task and which will
require the use of overwhelming force
this is a plot point that has to be
resolved before wano can properly
conclude and momo's statement that he is
not ready to open up the borders of wano
just yet hints at the fact that a
confrontation with this fleet is coming
now we know that luffy zorro and the
other heavy hitters on the straw hat
side are in no shape to engage in
another brutal fight at least not yet so
this showdown with the world government
fleet could play out in a few different
ways the first option is that the straw
hats will just escape wano before the
world government fleet can capture them
which would give luffy zoro sanji and
everyone else enough time to recover
from the kaido fight but that would be a
very anti-climactic ending to the wanos
story because the people of wanos still
wouldn't be free the superhuman effort
that everyone put into defeating kaido
and the beasts pirates will have been
all for nothing because the tyrannical
rule of kaido and orochi would just be
replaced by the tyrannical rule of the
world government the people of wano
would still be oppressed their dreams of
freedom would be shattered and the
entire arc would feel like a pretty big
letdown especially from the perspective
of wano's inhabitants oda has really
focused in on the struggle of wanos
people and on their dreams of freedom
many times over the course of this arc
so i don't see him just leaving them in
the hands of the world government as the
straw hats flee for their lives so what
else could potentially happen well
theoretically momo yamato the samurai of
wano and those members of the straw hats
and their allies who are still able to
fight could engage the world government
fleet in battle and win but that would
certainly extend this already long arc
even further and it would imply that the
world government sent a pretty
lackluster fleet to take on an enemy who
managed to defeat kaido if i was making
decisions for the world government i
would make sure that this fleet includes
fighters who are extremely strong if not
actual admirals themselves anything
short of that would just be bad planning
so if the fleet is extremely strong and
if the straw hats don't want to just run
away and leave wano to the world
government then it's possible that an
overpowered third party could intervene
to destroy the fleet quickly and move us
along to the next arc for example
zunesha could go beast mode and just
stomp out the entire fleet or the
revolutionaries could show up and
destroy the fleet or maybe blackbeard
will show up and take down the fleet for
some strange reason known only to him
but personally my favorite scenario
would be if shanks and the red hair
pirates showed up and took out the world
government fleet
luffy has now definitely proven that he
is a great pirate he literally took down
a yonko so what better time for the
long-awaited reunion between luffy and
shanks
just imagine luffy waking up from his
post-battle coma to see shanks standing
over him i mean we've been waiting for
this reunion for so long that it almost
seems like a mythical event at this
point it feels like the moment when it
finally happens will never come but with
everything that just happened in wano i
really do think that now is the perfect
time for shanks to reunite with luffy
shanks would then be able to reveal what
he knew and didn't know about the nika
devil fruit why he had a secret meeting
with the gorosei and what kaido's defeat
really means for the balance of power in
the world of one piece
shanks could also usher in the new major
arc in the story by telling luffy and
the others that they have to stop
blackbeard from taking over elbaf or
something along those lines and bam we
have the straw hat pirates and the red
hair pirates sailing together to the
legendary island of elbaf and don't even
get me started on how much meeting
shanks and his crew and then going to
elbaf would affect our boy usopp his
character development would finally
reach its ultimate climax like i said
shanks showing up in this moment is my
personal favorite scenario and i think
that it would make a lot of sense from a
narrative perspective but we'll have to
wait and see we've waited so long for
the epic reunion between luffy and
shanks that any scenario in which it
actually happens seems too good to be
true but speaking of elbaf many fans
believe that this will be the next major
arc in the story after all the loose
sands and guano are wrapped up so what
can we expect from a potential elbaf arc
the island of elbaf is famously
inhabited by giants and its culture and
architecture are inspired by the vikings
elbaf is sometimes referred to as the
strongest country in the world because
of the incredible strength of its giant
army and all the inhabitants of albath
live by a warrior's code of honor for
example if there's an argument or
dispute between giants and neither one
will yield they resolve it through a
battle to the death they believe that
the gods of elbaf will protect the one
who is in the right and so the righteous
one will win and the other one will lose
we first learned about this from dory
and brogi all the way back in chapter
116 usopp was so impressed by the
strength and bravery of the two giants
that he instantly came to think of them
as the exemplars for what a real man and
real warrior should be and usopp
expressed a strong desire to one day
visit elbaf over 900 chapters later the
moment to visit elbaf may finally be at
hand our knowledge of elbaf is quite
limited but we do have some key bits of
information albaf is located in the new
world in a region called warland which
is known for its extremely dangerous
waters and gigantic flora and fauna the
island appears to have large and steep
mountains and there seems to be a
gigantic tree at the center of the
island which is a reference to igdrassil
or the world tree from norse mythology
we also know that elbaf has a prince
named loki and this prince wanted to
marry big mom's daughter lola elbaf was
of course the location of big mom's
former orphanage and big mom aka linlin
is hated by giants all over the world
because of the rampage that she caused
on elbaf as a child big mom was actually
hoping that a marriage between prince
loki and lola would improve her
relationship with the giants but after
lola rejected the marriage and ran away
things got even worse between the giants
and the big mom pirates notably the
religion and culture of elbaf is heavily
centered around the sun and showing
gratitude to the sun and they appear to
worship a son god this means that
luffy's devil fruit the sun god nika
fruit may have a direct connection to
elbaf this is just one of many reasons
why fans believe that elbaf will be the
next major destination for the straw
hats and i tend to agree the only
question is how exactly elbaf will be
tied into the overall story and how it
might incorporate major characters like
dragon shanks and blackbeard at the
stage that the one piece story is at
right now i don't think we will see
another major arc that doesn't directly
involve the big unresolved plot points
in some way and i think that we can all
agree that the biggest loose plot points
are shanks blackbeard the
revolutionaries the one piece itself and
imusama as i mentioned earlier i could
totally see blackbeard attacking elbaf
for some reason and luffy teaming up
with shanks in order to stop him luffy
and shanks both have a personal history
and rivalry with blackbeard so it is
only fitting that the two of them would
face blackbeard's overpowered crew at
the same time the revolutionaries are
committed to taking down the world
government so it would make sense for
luffy to team up with his father dragon
to take down the celestial dragons and
imusama this means that we could be
looking at one major arc that involves
shanks and luffy versus blackbeard
possibly on elbaf then a laugh tale arc
and then the final showdown against the
world government and imusama that will
involve the entire straw hat fleet the
revolutionary army and every other ally
that luffy has made along the way
that said the order in which these
events occur could be different many
people would like blackbeard to be the
final villain not the world government
also it's possible that the straw hats
will find love tale before the final
battle and that they might even use what
they find on laughtale to win the final
battle but it is also possible that
finding love tale could be the very last
thing that happens in the story after
the final battle is already over as i
stated in previous videos i think that
finding love tale will occur before the
final battle and that the one piece
treasurer itself will be instrumental in
winning the war against the world
government if you're looking for a video
to watch next check out my video on what
the one piece actually is where i
suggested that the one piece may be a
giant island-sized battleship and that
the final battle will involve all three
ancient weapons coming together in one
piece to destroy the red line and create
the all blue the link to that video will
be in the description and in the pinned
comment and now i want to hear what you
guys think is wano really ending or are
we actually going to see the ark
continue for a bunch more chapters
because of the world government fleet do
you think that a major player like
shanks blackbeard or dragon could appear
in wano before the straw hats leave is
elbaf the next major destination or do
you have another location in mind let me
know down below if you guys enjoyed this
video and you want us to keep it going
with that one piece content leave a
quick like and comment it only takes a
second but it helps a lot and don't
forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell it is a direct and
completely free way of supporting the
channel you can also hit me up on
twitter and instagram at animeopror i
want to give a big thank you to all of
our anime outpour patrons for making
videos like this one possible special
thank you to kyle salisbury this man is
an absolute mad lad and a disciple of
lore twigo himself and i can't forget
all of our the one tier patrons the ones
who rise above all other clans including
alpha sigma pate heffa the red-haired
fox hinokami and water the toasted chi
corey mcgowan the fallen chosen orihime
wukong dante tinnell and big buddhist
finally thank you also to our pro hero
tier patrons including the one and only
gilgamesh angel cruz alicia octor bunny
parks fat boy games kaido might be a
duck alivania and anime s codem if you
guys enjoy our videos and you feel that
they provide value to you consider
supporting us on patreon as always thank
you guys so much for watching and until
next time see ya space cowboys